while sequence means it's like a list of
numbers okay so notice the commas here
so it's basically just a list a series
is a sum you're adding them together but
a sequence is a list now arithmetic
means that you're adding the same thing
to get to the next term and that thing
that you're adding is what's called D
the common difference now why do they
call it the common difference difference
means subtract if you take 21 minus 17
what do you get for if you take 25 minus
21 what are you getting for if you take
29 minus 25 what are you getting for so
what you can see is that common
difference is actually what we're adding
to get to the next term in the list or
in the sequence so that's why they call
it D for difference now the next thing I
wanted to mention to you is that this is
actually called N equals 1 N equals 2 N
equals 3 and so on this means this is
the first term second term third term
now another notation that you want to
pay attention to is like a sub 1 a sub 2
a sub 3 a sub 4 or less right over here
a sub 5 that means the value of the
fifth term and as the term number Tron
but a sub n is the value of that term
what that term actually equals so now we
want to talk about is how do we find out
what the term is right here well notice
this is the one two three four five
sixth term okay so I'm just gonna write
N equals six how do we get to the sixth
term well you start off at 17 right and
then what you do is you add four now how
many times are we adding four well we're
adding four once twice three times four
times five times and a lot of students
they'll save hmm you found the sixth
term but you add added four or five
times how come not six times you know
well the thing is we're already on the
first term so to get to the sixth term
we only have to add four one less time
okay so if we wanted to generalize this
a little bit more you could say well
this is a sub one that's the value of
the first term that's 17 plus D that's
the common difference that's what we're
adding to get to the next term and you
want to add that D and minus one times
okay so in this case we're adding four
or five times that's 20 plus 17 that's
37 which makes sense because we were
adding four each time so now what we
have is we have a what they call an
explicit
formula meaning that it'll take you
right to any particular term so let's
write this in a little bit more general
way a sub n equals a sub one plus D
times n minus one so for this problem we
had let's see we had a sub n equal 17
that's the first term else our common
difference is just four times n minus 1
now what I would do is I'd clean this up
a little bit by distributing okay
17 and negative 4 is how much that's 13
and so now what we have is we have a sub
N equals 13 plus 4n and that'll allow us
to find any term if I want the hundredth
term I put in a hundred that's four
hundred and thirteen and you know you've
got it so it's a real nice it takes you
right to that